[Music]
Ugh, I’m going to make a movie for the first time, so nobody believes
me.
A monk is a
late film director. From 20 years ago, everyone on this planet wanted to make
their life beautiful and green forever.
I thought I had to do it with something visible, so
I thought I should make a movie now.
[Music]
One day, a male secretary passed by in our chin and saw us making English, and we were sad when we hid behind us.
I asked the Woos how to make a movie together again. I asked them if they believed
I was making a movie. No, I didn’t even cry
.  Do you only make movies?
When it was not your full-time job, what happened to the monk Do? After knowing that the answer was a monk,
I tried to watch a movie again in both theaters and try to make a gap
.
I took it to the
film festival with it and submitted it to the film festival.
Uh, other films say they are one, but after watching our film, no one of the judges
said a
word.
The
judges said that it was a high movie, so it was a film that could not be judged on . But the judges
unanimously gave the grand prize
[Music] Uh [Music]
My first feature film I made this time is
uh  A movie that had a discussion about . No.
Religion is like a tree in the harbor. So uh, the origin of that tree is now  We are looking for
the root, the root of the tree.
The uproot is covered with soil and can't be seen anymore.
Oh, so I wanted to eat a stepping stone to find the root through the movie Suwon on
the Ship.  Everyone, it's
dangerous, the police force
has to go. Oh, and I misunderstood a lot. Wasn't
that a nun? Did you go out in disguise
?
I'm very curious about those parts, whether he was prepared or whether he wrote the screenplay,
and rather than worrying about it,
I think he focused more on his intentions than on
the essential elements that could be misunderstood.  Now the staff are more or
less famous.
And now that I'm a customer, I don't think I know very well, and now I'm doing
it.
[Music]
Ah, the false acting doesn't work with the director.
There are scenes where you only pretend to be like that.
Variable type, never let go. That's true.
Now I understand what the director said while filming this movie.
I was just
relaxed and I didn't listen to the pending issues,
but despite the rumors coming out, the director
seems to have made a really good scene for that harmony
.  There is no need to put effort into packaging,
so at first,
it was a little unfamiliar and a little uncomfortable because of that,
but now, now that I know more about the director,
I think it’s a lot more comfortable.
I was able to produce it as a result  Bang
oh oh sola Once you shoot,
you must outdo people as if to notify them
, and then leave Akashida Yale and press only one force to tickle the part of the burger and the my pet again in the light of light.
I just cried after watching the movie.
But my father said let's solve it. He's a pillar member
and he came out of the house after 107 years of fighting over that religious issue
.
There is one thing that I felt big,
but I don't think that we are different, but I think I learned the attitude to understand the other person a little more,
and
the attitude to love more like
this.
Yes, it is a phenomenon that can be done by making a boat out of white paper, and seeing the boat is paper
.
I can’t help it, I want this
[music]
we
oh oh
wer uh
[music]
9 5